I went over the basics of objects in a
previous video now I'll talk about other
things you can do with objects you can
see the list of what we will cover on
the screen the first thing is using
objects for lookups objects can be
thought of as key value storage like a
dictionary if you have tabular data you
can use an object to look up values in
the data he's an example of a simple
reverse alphabet lookup so you just
create the data you want in in this
alpha object so one is Z 2 is y 3 is X
and then so on I'm not going to put all
the letters in there but then you can
just do console that log alpha 2 so you
can find out what letter is the second
letter in the reverse alphabetic next up
is removing object properties so I'm
going to create this object here dishes
with plates 8 cups tents and so on and
if you just do delete the name of the
objects and in the name of the property
it's going to delete that that property
but let me run that and you can see
right in here there are no more cups and
the Y appeared from the reverse lookup
now testing objects for properties
sometimes it is useful to check if the
property of a given object exists or not
I briefly discussed this in my previous
video you just use a hair's own property
method on the object so dishes that
heads on property plates dishes that
heads on property cops or checking if we
have to fill it we have the property
plates and cups we deleted the property
cups so we have true it has plates and
false it does not have cups okay now
we're going to talk about accessing and
modifying nested objects object
properties can be nested to any depth
and their values can be any type of data
supported by Java Script including
arrays and even other objects so the sub
properties of objects can be accessed by
chaining together the dot or bracket
notation in this object called our
stores we have two properties desk and
cabinet but each of the properties desk
and cabinet contains an object as the
value so here's an object that just
contains the property drawer here's an
object that contains the object top
drawer top drawer and bottom drawer and
inside
the top drawer we have another object so
we can access an object within another
objects by using the data bracket
notation so right here with our storage
that cam net here's the dot notation to
access the camera and then we're gonna
use the bracket notation which you
always need the bracket notation anytime
the property has a space in it so we're
gonna get to this top drawer and then
we're gonna use the dot notation again
to get inside the folder - and then here
we're just looking at inside our storage
that depth that drawer which we write
here you can also use the bracket dot
notation to assign a new value to a
property that's nested inside an object
so here we have the cabinet top drawer
that folder - that's all we have up here
but instead of just console dot logging
it we are going to use the assignment
operator the equal sign to set that to
cake recipe and then I'm gonna log it
again first of all and folder - we have
secrets which you can see here and then
we're just going to check what's in the
drawer which is a stapler what you can
see here then we're going to assign
folder to the cake recipe and we're
going to log folder two again and now
it's not secrets anymore it's just a
cake recipe which anybody can learn and
the last thing I'm gonna cover in this
video is how to generate an array of all
object keys and the object either just
the properties we can generate an array
that contains all the keys stored in an
object using the object that keys method
and passing in an object as the argument
this will return an array with strings
representing each property in the object
so we're gonna call object that keys
you're not gonna put the reference to
the object you're gonna actually put the
word object that keys and then you're
gonna put what the object is inside
these parentheses here and you can see
in our storage we just have desk and
cabinet because it's only going to give
the first level so I'm gonna go into the
object to get the second the nested
objects well thanks for watching my name
is beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good